Boris Johnson likes to say Brett's it's
done but there are many in Europe who
disagree these ministers open in the
next chapter in brexit battles over our
future trade deal the EU signing off on
its new red lines before negotiations
begin next week we are ready to offer a
highly ambitious trade dealer to the UK
paducah cannot expect high quality
access to the single market if it is not
prepared to accept guarantees that
competition remains open and fair and
here in black and white the EU cleared
the UK must maintain common high
standards when it comes to state aid
environmental and labor laws and not
just for now but for the future too but
back in Westminster the cabinet drawer
in red lines of their own they are for
now United brexit means not being a rule
taker this is a negotiation as you know
but we are completely independent nation
after brexit and we will be respectful
of them and no more expect them to
follow our rules than we'll follow that
this former trade secretary isn't sure
if a deal will happen by the end of the
year but he does believe the UK's
entering this negotiation in better
shape than its opponents we all know in
politics that the most useful currency
is power and Boris Johnson has a lot of
that at the present time we've got a
clear mandate we have a big majority and
we are going to be able to argue our
case with a certainty that we can
deliver at home that wasn't possible in
the past now the EU we already know is
having sharp divisions of opinion over
for example how they fill the gap left
by Britain's budgetary contributions not
being there this was once the place for
bitter brexit divisions but the election
changed all of that
mr. Johnson's won the right to chart
Britain's direction Boris Johnson sat
out his negotiating position later this
week but the Prime Minister has already
made one thing
crystal clear for him taking back
control means sovereignty trumps all
else and if that means friction at the
borders in a hit to the economy in
return for British autonomy well so be
it
some one-on-one diplomacy today the PM
host in his Austrian counterpart in
Downing Street friends for now but the
negotiations are yet to really start and
when they do relationships will be
tested
Beth Rigby Sky News Westminster